over my years of being with nfl network
and nfl total access i've interviewed
many an nflpa president starting with
trace armstrong back in the day now an
agent
troy vincent who's now at the league and
then kevin mawi who's in the pro
football hall of fame those were the
first three
and uh a center is back under center as
the president of the nflpa welcome to
the rich eisen show jc tretter
of the cleveland browns how are you jc
i'm doing well thanks for having me on a
pleasure to chat with you
so uh let's just jump right into it uh
if you don't mind
is there a boycott of voluntary
offseason in-person activities going on
with the nfl players association in the
nfl
well i i don't think boycotts the word
um i think to start the off-season
is voluntary and that has slowly
lost its definition over time when it
comes to voluntary offseason workouts
uh and i think some of the media and
some fans
and i know a lot of the teams have
stopped looking at voluntary as meaning
actually voluntary
um and i think guys right now are making
an informed decision about what's in
their best interest
uh when it comes to their health and
safety and that's what being a
professional is all about
is making informed decisions for what's
best for your your health your career
and guys are doing that um and we're
seeing those those people come out and
come forward and say what they want to
do moving forward
okay so is there is there there's no
coordination
occurring at the union level with all
the teams there's now
four uh based on my account including
the
defending super bowl champs which will
definitely um get some attention
um is there no coordination between
these teams at all uh between the teams
no but that
we're we're the union so when when guys
have questions and guys want to know
what's going on in negotiations what
whether they're gonna be protected what
are the protocols
uh we give them those answers and we
give them that
that data and that information so um
we're we're in contact with all the
teams because that's our job as a union
is
informing our players on on what's going
on and and what they uh
what information they need so how many
teams do you expect
um based on the information that they've
been asking for and that has been
provided to them
to wind up with similar stances as the
lions bucks seahawks and broncos as you
and i currently are talking
jc tretter uh it really comes down to
each
each person making their individual
choice so
those conversations will continue to
happen i'm sure
but if we just take a step back for a
second we did this
all of last year we had a virtual off
season
and some feared what would happen with
injuries or what would happen with the
product on the field
and what we saw was injuries were down
we had a 23
drop in missed time injuries last year
uh we had a 30
reduction in concussions nearly every
type of injury was down or
flat compared to their five-year trends
and then when it comes to the
product we saw scoring be up we saw the
margin of victory
be as as close as it's been in over a
decade
we've seen more teams in the playoff
hunt at the end of the season
than ever before we've saw more come
from behind victories than ever before
so when injuries are down imperative and
dramas up
and scoring's up it starts to point to
the fact that this
isn't necessary and when when you go
back
all you're risking is getting hurt and
potentially
losing out on making the team guys are
going to have to start making a decision
on what's best
that's in a normal year what's going on
right now is
kobet's still going on and we're at
three times the daily cases that we had
last year at this time
and we're not back to normal so there
are there are decisions to be made with
a pandemic going on that last year we
both agreed the nfl and the nfl pa
that's in everybody's best interest to
just stay safe and stay apart
for a while and now you hear stories
like jason tatum come out
and talk about how he'd have to take an
inhaler before every game because he's
still feeling the
the effects of covid miles garrett
talked about it publicly this year so as
a player
when you're looking at all this
information why would you go
back in april may june
risk catching covid and then when you
actually have to perform
during the season you might be still
feeling the ill effects of that that
would
affect your performance affect whether
you make the team
guys have to make those decisions for
themselves now casey treader brown
center
and nflpa president here on the rich
eisen show
so uh when bruce arian says something
along the lines of first second and
third year players are not
going to be as advanced because of the
lost
time in voluntary workouts and that they
might lose their gigs to veterans
how do you respond to that uh
my job in our job as a union is to know
what our players want
and this is what our players want and we
surveyed our players and the vast
majority of our players
think the virtual off-season is the best
for this year
and that wasn't just the veteran saying
that just as many young guys just as
many guys with one year of experience
two years of experience three years of
experience
responded saying that they think the
virtual offseason is the best thing for
them
this year as the older guys did so
that's
a narrative that just doesn't have any
factor or proof to it it's just
used to try to uh divide
the the union but we know what we want
we we as players talk and we as a union
are in charge of representing what all
players want
and that's what we're doing no and look
this is not my first rodeo on this
subject matter jc
uh it is the first time we're having a
conversation that
um you know i i i've seen the
the concept of voluntary be put in air
quotes and then assumed to be mandatory
and i've seen how many players bristle
because
they're painted as being less than a
team player because of it
and um and so and where does it stop
like you know you do negotiate to have
something
actually termed mandatory so for those
mandatory
scenarios the the teams that are are
saying right now they're not going to
appear the players on these teams that
they're not going to appear
um for voluntary workouts they still
plan on
appearing for the mandatory sessions is
that true yeah
we would surely advise them to there are
contractual obligations about being
there for the mandatory portions
um and we would surely explain that to
everybody about
why you have to be there what's in your
contract and what would the
repercussions be if you don't show up to
the mandatory portion of it
okay and just a couple other um you know
i guess viewpoints to to put it to in
your direction for your response on it
what about the concept that the the
facilities
were um for the lack of a better phrase
as
hardened against covet as they possibly
could just a .08 percent
uh positivity rate last year so
what would be the concern of actually
appearing in
a facility that has been set up
similarly to last year
for a voluntary workout the off season
and the regular season are two
completely different
parts of the year with completely
different rules on what would go on
so the off season you only need to be
there four days a week
if you want credit those are those the
amount of days a team can hold you
so guys are free to leave guys didn't
leave their home cities
during the season we had a virtual
bubble guys stayed dedicated to staying
in town staying year round
all year for the season they tested
every day
that will not be going on so we don't
know what our facilities will look like
so we we can't compare what happened
last year during the regular season
to what would go on this year in the off
season because the protocols will not be
the same
there will be giant holes and openings
for koba to get in the building
and that's what guys are are realizing
just how different the regular season
would be compared to what this would
look like as an off-season program
and what about the concept of
vaccination that if uh
that if everyone was vaccinated that
this might be a
a different scenario in a different
conversation is the nf what's the nfl
pa's
stance on having the membership
vaccinated
jc we've yeah we've we've provided
information and we have a medical great
medical director and tom mayer where we
allow guys to ask those questions i have
gotten my first shot
but i won't be fully vaccinated until
mid-may
and if you haven't gotten your first
shot yet you might not be fully
vaccinated
till june comes around which is the
entire offseason program so
vaccinations are great to talk about but
they're they're just not going to be
part of this conversation
um as of right now because it's the
timeline to get fully vaccinated
wouldn't have been completed by by the
time that the offseason would be
completed all right so then let's look
over the steering wheel towards a
playing season that's coming up jc
treader the league sent out a
a memo to essentially say uh
league employees or team employees that
are not vaccinated or not allowed around
folks like you
uh tier one and tier two um and it
seemed to me reading that memo that i
guess
lead the league's leaving up the
mandating
concept of vaccinations to the union so
what what is the union's stance on
telling players
to get vaccinated in time for the
playing season
is there one yeah the league's made it
clear they're not gonna they're not
gonna mandate vaccines for the players
um and in our stances we're gonna allow
players to make their decision we're
providing them all the
information we think guys need to read
it understand it and make the best
decision for themselves
that's been our position um and and
that's what we need guys to do and that
that's going to take time that's going
to take
we've seen kind of the slow growth and
the vaccination rate in the nba
that's not done overnight it takes time
and
that's why we're you know providing
opportunities for guys to talk and learn
and talk to our medical director and
talk to
experts on the field just to feel
comfortable in what they're doing and so
do you what's your general sense as the
president do you think that there is a
sense that
much of the uh players association is
going to get vaccinated in time for the
season or do you think that there is a
considerable pushback we saw my
colleague at the nfl
network through his podcast kyle brandt
talked to josh allen and josh definitely
seemed like somebody who
had to think about it and might actually
lean against it
what's your general sense jc i think
we're
i think we're people so i always try to
look at we are just a microcosm
of the general population and i think
we'll probably fall down a similar line
of that
so um i i don't know i don't think we're
any different
or we look at the world any different we
are just normal people who have the same
beliefs as
as people who aren't professional
football players
and that's going to be kind of how we
how we fall but again i i think all the
vaccination talk i think we're very
hopeful that we will be back to normal
and we can have full stadiums and have
the fans back
in september but april isn't september
and we're we're nowhere near those
points now and that's one of the issues
we're having right now is the nfl has
this feeling of we're going to be normal
for the regular season so let's just go
back to normal now
and we're not normal now so uh jc tread
a few minutes left with the cleveland
brown center here uh on the rich eisen
show
the uh the season for the cleveland
browns uh
that you guys had last year was
stupendous
i i know you might not have gotten as
far as you had hoped
but there was a major leap forward
why what happened last year jc that you
can actually put into
terms talk a little football with you
before i let you yeah i give a ton of
credit
for to kevin stefanski and andrew barry
for coming in and
developing the culture that they want
for the team um
and you know we we just really came
together and it was not tough that's why
kevin deserved so much credit
uh for being a first-year head coach
coming into a year like last year with
the protocols and the all virtual
offseason and all those things to be
able to step
in implement your system implement your
program
and find immediate success shows just
what a quality coach
and human being and leader he is um
and that's what did he he built a team
he built the team camaraderie
um and and built us into uh a great team
and that i kind of
the saddest part is we wish we i always
think back to that pittsburgh game
at cleveland week 17 to go to the
playoffs
and i just wish the the world was
different
we could have had a sold out crowd for
that and to see the dog pound back
um for that game would have been great
that that's just a missed a missed
opportunity we are very
hopeful for many more of those to come
but that that's one i wish we
we could have uh experienced the full
taste of cleveland brown football
i'm sure of it but you're you obviously
that's your point is
there's there's more to come um
obviously
in terms of proximity on the field
nobody's closer than you to baker
mayfield
um what what change occurred do you
think with stefanski and him
look it's it's it's a it's a maturation
process for anybody regardless of a
first overall selection or 199 overall
like brady
but uh wha what what uh in your
estimation from your point of view
um occurred with with baker mayfield for
him to take that leap
last year baker's always been a leader
uh so that's the first thing you saw
when he walked in the building as a
rookie
and then he continued to develop as as a
player and as a leader and becomes a
better leader
um and a better player and that takes
time everybody continues to get better
as you work
and i think baker has just absolutely
worked his tail off all of last
offseason all of this
this past season and even this offseason
talking to him you see how much work
he's putting in
i'm excited to see him come back and see
all the growth
he'll have between the end of last year
when we get started this year
and then just uh i guess to bring it all
full circle do the cleveland browns
uh plan on appearing for voluntary
off-season workouts or
might you and your colleagues and
brethren
join the other four teams that have made
a statement that they're not showing
yeah that'll be a individual decision
that we'll talk about as a team we
haven't had that conversation yet but
i don't i don't speak for for the
cleveland browns i don't speak for every
guy in the cleveland browns
uh we'll we'll talk to them just like
the other teams are having these
conversations and every guy will make
their
their choice on what they want to do why
are centers so good at this
job for the president jc because i and
it's not just
he wasn't the president at the time but
i i had a whole half hour long
conversation with jeff
saturday on nfl network during the
lockout when the winter was very very
cold
in the middle of the summer what is it
about centers
it makes this summer oh i don't know i
mean we have a ton of leaders in the
locker room
and in the union uh our executive
committee is is great
and we have a no we have al smack on
that but we have a ton of other
uh clay campbell richard sherman michael
thomas uh we we have a bunch of really
great leaders on the executive committee
and as reps
but uh it might just be a coincidence
that a couple centers have have taken
the lead in some issues but uh
there are a lot of really quality people
and quality leaders all across locker
rooms well i guess let's be honest
i'm not to be coward and trying to you
know um
snag on your quarterback here but uh if
baker was such a leader how come you're
not in a progressive commercial with him
i i've let him know that i noticed that
the rookie left tackle got the first
jump into the uh the the commercial than
uh some of his older
uh teammates so i i've made that clear
to him but no it's uh
he does that he does a hell of a job on
those you i mean you're you went to
cornell you could be in the book club
jc come on i would definitely fit that
i would definitely fit that uh that role
well
yes you could get in the stands with the
book club waiting for for
someone to show you can do that i mean
let's just pound the table i'll just do
my best to pound the table for you
i love it i love it i i need all the
help i can get jc appreciate the time in
the chat um
i know these are interesting times let's
uh let's keep talking if you don't mind
good luck um
in the off season and um and uh we'll
chat down the line
absolutely appreciate me you bet that's
jc tretter
the president of the players association
and the cleveland browns
center right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here